hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to troll face quest - now
there was enough demand after I played
the first game that people really wanted
to see the second one and apparently
there's a third and a fourth that I
didn't know about and there may be a
fifth on a six I don't know you guys
might be trolling me back but also I'm
going to be deliriously tired while I
play through the entire game because it
is currently 459 and you may be asking
yourself what are you doing up at this
ungodly hour
well it wasn't my choice what is with
that bird that bird is very unhappy
about his forehead situation so don't
expect me to make a lot of sense for
this entire playthrough because frankly
I don't even know what I am and how I do
that that bird looks like a dick I'm
going to be slap-happy now it looks like
a Rovio that one looks like it has
problems I mean I did it good great for
me I used my brain to exercise my brain
oh hey oh I thought that was your dick
sticking out of your pants for a second
there sorry this is your gun or is that
a handkerchief I don't even know
probably don't want to know okay
super duper vib Club 9 oh I get that a
boob oh my god blow that out what a
birdie you do not know bird oh yes it's
me mister Obama President Obama if you
don't mind oh you gotta take my picture
okay
oh my face I'm dead for some reason oh
boy give me your hat stop laughing at me
oh no not again in my face
okay how about touch that little weird
lump on your neck
oh okay I clicked on my face before I
didn't know that oh hey how's your own
there okay I'm not gonna share I'm
already sharing it with the world oh hey
you look like you're ready for a
disturbance there mr. moon man okay go
press D no okay you son of a [ __ ] house
well how's that even a failure you just
had a cloud move in front of my way mr.
moon man
oh yes censor that out but we got the
boob like faucet handles over here or do
you want some water there Berto oh poor
low hey how's it going mr. tickle han
string trollface guy still dead okay
still dead okay all right I guess my
bird friend is gonna be hiding at all
blazes what is that supposed to be an
airport I'm not entirely sure hey buddy
how you doing back there
good good tips hi
I'm typing furiously okay that made
sense I just got a deadly dose of x-rays
in my face that's fine
hey mr. moon man Hey Oh
leave for this well [ __ ] didn't need to
do that now I'm dead - great cool ok ok
I'm lost
I've looked through just about every
single goddamn piece of this these
goddamn level ain't nothing to be done
about it
well supposed to like click on something
on the things like I thought maybe the
Bears you but now it just dies like
[ __ ] whoa what the hell stupid the
button for the Walker I didn't get that
from the walkthrough because the walls
every button doesn't work I just what
the hell happened
okay
oh how did I not do that there's got to
be something with this because I know
that it did something in the last game
where I was like twelve face there is
shut up get out of my face I'm playing a
game here I want the candy I've wanted
so badly oh I want it so badly
well alright then my bird just exploded
off to the other screen oh how are you
going to expose your dick and renovate
our time so simple yet I or trollolol
hanok always I just want to do something
about that I was supposed to do
something about that I was too
enthralled into Titanic at the story
drop the main anchor drop the main well
[ __ ] we're all died Rose didn't even get
to bang the artist what's Leonardo to
take that mr. iceberg man or no a shark
am i out in the middle of the ocean
is it time call out to all the fangirls
and boys and sergeants a mark of our in
the middle of the yard
never mind I mean never mind I'm dead
don't worry about me guys I'm dead don't
worry
what doesn't make any sense did the same
damn thing I just did shut up well [ __ ]
I clicked somewhere
I guess I just stopped asking you for
this to make that wait a minute here all
right
cuckoo how do you how do you do do oh
well they all match now what do I do now
maybe I could use the legs or something
oh okay all right
once again really really simple I'm
really really stupid
so don't pit bear with me also I'm
losing sleep so just gig Hey hi Oh
getting warmer
Oh too hot too hot too hot
Oh No well [ __ ] that didn't work I
probably was supposed to stop at some
point in case it's cold did not stop the
heat from the horizon
Oh oh there we go okay I guess I'll just
go inside now and then the temperature
will stop cuz that's how nature way hey
how's it going there are you the guy
from off are you that big guy from off I
don't remember how your voice went cool
it's always gonna be a fakery yeah liar
yeah dirty liar hello oh that's gross
disgusting why was that a thing that
happened oh hey can you stop this is
like the beginning of among the sleep
well add more water please
well that didn't stop it dooby doo boo
boo boo boo boo thank you very much hey
so so what's the point of that so thanks
Oh clicking hold I thought I heard a
noise before but then anything really
like the Buddha Boogedy boo boo I'm
gonna win yay like a failure that seems
like a win in my book and I'm not even
looking at it I ain't very emotionally
involved in this apparently Manuel Oh
Manuel does that mean I can ah yes this
is good it's good it's good cuz I'm
smart and use my brain is this where
we're gonna drink poison again
alright okay bye dad this is killing me
it feels like oh you did
Oh gotcha
oh hey pirate man give me your keys no
I'll give me your key having a bazooka
something well I was ooh could everybody
i blew down glued it up
give me bird oh no my birdie fell over
kaboom
this doesn't make any sense I'm gonna
take your peg leg how about I take your
other leg I'm so adorable anybody would
throw be anything finds its way what
game please so what I did it I got the
victory is now mine I've longed for this
day longingly for as long as I long
lived and now I shall open the chest
claim my did you eat all my mm of love
really very little bit amount of my time
in my life and how dare you sir it's the
way the way I hope you got a kick out of
this tired let's play because frankly I
don't even know before I have to go pass
out over there on the couch over there
so anyway thank you guys so much for
watching hope you enjoyed it hope you
enjoyed it and hope you enjoyed it I'm
gonna go to sleep now thanks again
everybody from oh but either way thank
you guys so much for watching thank you
for being here with me thank you for
joining me on a big adventure let me
know if you want to see the other ones
and if you enjoy this stupid glorious
version of 12 ace quest - and lies in
store for 3 and 4 so thanks again and
here comes more okay spooky
started